1984 a été une année difficile les vents
ont baissées notre croissance à ralenti
chenille je t'ai fait venir chez nous
pour développer le business du basket
ça veut dire quoi Converse c'est la
chaussure des All Stars
tu auras intérêt à avoir un argumentaire
en béton j'ai un argument qu'aucun de
nos concurrents ne peut avancer notre
service basket est catastrophique je
suis pas fan du tout
c'est le moment d'avoir un éclair de
génie et de dénicher la perle je
t'écoute
ça y est je l'ai trouvé ah ouais qui ça
Dieu on a pas les moyens je suis prêt à
miser ma carrière sur un mec
je m'appelle Sony bakao je travaille
chez Nike et ça vous prend souvent de
débarquer comme ça à l'improviste chez
les gens j'ai du mal à supporter qu'on
me dise non
ça commence tu m'as demandé ce que je
faisais ici tata réponse je trouve des
joueurs et cette fois je le sens bien
oui d'accord c'est risqué et quand tu
vendais des chaussures de sport dans le
coffre de ta bagnole c'était risqué
aussi ne change pas ce que tu es tu veux
un roquet ouais un gars qui a jamais
foutu les pieds sur un parquet pro c'est
précisément la définition du mot ok
ouais
c'est quoi le plan on crée une
collection de chaussures exclusivement
autour de lui
dessine-moi la plus incroyable
chaussures jamais fabriquées c'est qui
le mec
[Musique]
Michael Jordan
vous avez toute notre attention
[Musique]
croire en votre fils je crois qu'il est
l'avenir mais son histoire va nous
donner envie de voler une chaussure
c'est qu'une chaussure jusqu'à ce que
mon fils la met au pied
[Musique]
tu as trouvé un nom
alors Jordan
j'ai un doute tu rigoles peut-être
[Musique]